[Música]
es el prototipo perfecto de país que
nunca dejó atrás el esquema de poder del
Antiguo imperio comunista de esta forma
siguiendo el mejor patrón de las
películas de Hollywood cada vez que
hablan de la república sexoviéticas Y es
un país relativamente pobre dirigido con
mano de hierro por un estrafalario
tirano ojo lo de tirano no no lo decimos
nosotros os recordamos que es algo de lo
que se jacta el mismo el gobierno
autoritario es algo propio de mí siempre
lo admitido es mejor ser dictador que
ser gay Alexander lukashenko presidente
de Bielorrusia hablamos de un dictador
que ante la crisis de inflación que se
vive en el mundo no se le ha ocurrido
Nada mejor que prohibir por ley la
inflación Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien
la inflación prohibida en Bielorrusia
Bielorrusia prohíbe los aumentos de los
precios al consumidor en un intento por
domar la inflación a ver en este vídeo
no vamos a contaros Por qué intentar
prohibir supone desde el punto de vista
económico un gigantesco error eso se lo
dejamos a visual economic Claro que esta
no es la única medida tomada por este
tirano para contener los precios habéis
oído hablar de la movilización general
para la recogida de patatas pues fijaos
Bielorrusia Lucas movilizar a los niños
para cosechar patatas y manzanas empezó
con los niños y terminó metiendo en el
saco a medio país
sea como sea esta no es la razón por la
que vinieron Rusia protagonizar este
vídeo Lo cierto es que más allá de su
peculiar política económica en los
últimos tiempos lukasenko está
acaparando la atención internacional y
lo está haciendo Ni más ni menos que por
ser el país que más apoya la terrible
invasión rusa de Ucrania Incluso se está
especulando con que finalmente
Bielorrusia pueda sumarse a la ofensiva
contra su vecino del Sur
por ejemplo en junio el gobierno del
conocido como último dictador de Europa
anunció la creación del Comando
operativo del sur una fuerza de combate
que se desplegará a lo largo de la
frontera con Ucrania también anunció la
ampliación del ejército y más
recientemente a comienzos de octubre
confirmó que se creará un contingente
militar conjunto con Rusia y en
principio esto supondrá la llegada al
país de miles de Soldados del país de
los zares según el régimen de lucasenko
se ha tomado esta decisión para proteger
sus fronteras hacemos hincapié una vez
más en que las tareas del grupo de
fuerza regional son puramente defensivas
y todas las actividades llevadas a cabo
en este momento tienen como objetivo
proporcionar una respuesta suficiente a
las acciones cerca de nuestras fronteras
Víctor krening ministro de defensa de
Bielorrusia por supuesto nadie se lo ha
creído el propio presidente ucraniano
celenski hizo saltar las alarmas durante
la siguiente sesión del g7 y propuso
enviar equipos de Naciones Unidas a la
frontera entre Ucrania y Bielorrusia
para evitar una nueva escalada en el
conflicto en la frontera entre Ucrania
Rusia podemos colocar una misión de
observadores Internacionales para
monitorear la situación de seguridad
nuestros diplomáticos pueden elaborar el
formato te pido a nivel del g7 que
apoyes esta iniciativa bueno dormir
felensky presidente de Ucrania esto por
supuesto No ocurrirá porque como todos
sabemos a la hora de la verdad Y más
allá de la política de los gestos y las
declaraciones la ONU pues no vale gran
cosa
[Música]
El caso es que como nadie se crea
lukashenko y los movimientos militares
en Rusia y Bielorrusia no dejan de
sucederse al tiempo que los rusos están
perdiendo la guerra Claro está ha
surgido por todas partes una pregunta
Hasta qué punto está Bielorrusia
pensando en unirse a la ofensiva rusa
contra Ucrania para que se va a utilizar
Exactamente esa especie de ejército
conjunto que era anunciado que podría
suponer esto para el ejército ucraniano
en este vídeo te vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
tenemos otra cuestión que responder por
qué demonios lucasengo sigue apoyando a
Putin atentos
Por cierto stop stop te hago una
pregunta que quizás nunca te has hecho
pero que Seguro seguro te va a interesar
Cuánta riqueza per cápita acumulada
crees que hay en todo el mundo es decir
como de ricos somos realmente Y cómo
oposición a tu país en este particular
ranking Pues bien según un estudio de la
consultora mckinsey la riqueza mundial
asciende Ni más ni menos que unos
65.800 dólares por cabeza la pregunta es
has acertado y ahora que sabemos Cuál es
la cifra nos surgen muchas más
cuestiones Cómo se distribuye y cómo se
invierte toda esta enorme riqueza cómo
está evolucionando En qué países crece
más pues amigos amigas Si queréis
conocer todas estas respuestas no os
podéis perder el último vídeo de si lo
hubiera sabido el canal financiero de
moto activos con el que participamos os
dejo el enlace en los comentarios dicho
esto Ahora sí vayamos con el último
dictador de Europa
de la desobediencia a la sumisión
Alexander rucasenko lleva gobernando
este país desde 1994 Durante este tiempo
su régimen se ha transformado ha pasado
de ser un gobierno autoritario más o
menos suave a un autocracia cada vez más
corrupta y más represiva una dictadura
que mantiene encarcelados a más de 1.300
presos políticos y que ha convertido el
país en un desierto de alternativas
políticas a pesar de ser un régimen
terriblemente impopular por supuesto por
el camino la libertad de prensa
desaparecido por completo y eso que con
un pib de poco más de 7.000 dólares per
cápita uno de los más bajos de toda
Europa se estima que apenas el 25% de la
población apoyados simpatiza con este
gobierno hablamos sobre todo de
pensionistas burócratas y miembros de
los equipos de seguridad por supuesto lo
que no consigue con apoyo popular el
gobierno lo consigue con la fuerza de
las pistolas las porras y las esposas lo
que en cierta forma se asemeja mucho a
la situación política que se está
viviendo en la madre Rusia y hablando de
Rusia Aunque era Putin y lukashenko
parezcan casi hermanos de sangre y
socios inquebrantables Lo cierto es que
no siempre se han llevado también
[Música]
1999 El dictador bielorruso firmó un
acuerdo con el presidente ruso Boris
yelsin para crear una Unión política y
económica total entre los dos países la
idea era crear una entidad supranacional
que con el tiempo terminará siendo
responsable de la política económica la
política exterior y la defensa Incluso
se especuló que con el tiempo los países
terminarían teniendo una misma moneda
tribunales comunes e incluso un
parlamento único pero lo que resulta más
sorprendente es que todo apunta que en
aquel momento el líder bielorruso pensó
que el mismo llegaría a dirigir este
mega bloque es decir la jugada que tenía
mente lukashenko era algo así como una
especie de Opa donde El pequeño se comía
al grande su idea es que Bielorrusia
terminara controlando toda Rusia
sin embargo con la llegada de Putin al
poder Esos planes se fueron al garete y
la pavelorrusia se dio la vuelta de
repente el acuerdo se convirtió en algo
así como una puerta a la anexión de este
país por parte de Rusia y Por ese motivo
lukasenko frenó el seco todo el proceso
y no solo eso tras
que parecía alineada con Moscú empezó a
verle las orejas al lobo y la pregunta
es qué creéis que hizo Entonces el
último dictador de Europa Pues
básicamente querer jugársela Moscú
estrechando lazos con occidente de hecho
ni siquiera reconoció a crimea como
parte de Rusia y las relaciones Se
volvieron cada vez más y más tensas
hasta el año 2020
ese año en 2020 hubo elecciones unas
elecciones por supuesto amañadas por
lukashenko que ganó con el 80% de los
votos Ya sabes para que no haya dudas
pero el caso es que en esta ocasión las
cosas no se iban a quedar así la
indignación Popular se tradujo en una
revueltas enormes que estuvieron a punto
de tumbar al dictador y la siguiente
pregunta es qué pensáis que ocurrió pues
amigos amigas básicamente que Putin se
convirtió en algo así como el salvavidas
del tirano bielo ruso envió
propagandistas equipos de seguridad
dinero y finalmente incluso confirmó que
intervendría militarmente es decir que
mandaría los tanques Para apoyar a su
nuevo amigo porque por supuesto todo
este apoyo no fue a cambio de nada a
partir de ese momento Lucas senco se
convertiría en un títere de Moscú y los
planes para la integración progresiva de
ambos países Se volvieron a poner sobre
la mesa Pero por qué demonios le
interesa tanto al crimen en este país
pues este es el motivo
[Música]
Rusia ha intentado hacer crecer sus
vínculos políticos económicos y
militares con Bielorrusia desde los años
90 sin embargo este esfuerzo se ha
multiplicado desde el 2020 son tres las
razones que explican tanto interés y que
este sea un asunto absolutamente
estratégico para el kremlin primero
Bielorrusia era importante para la
economía rusa porque por este país
pasaba más del 20% de todas las
exportaciones rusas de gasa Europa en
segundo lugar este país es el camino más
corto para llegar al obras de
kaliningrado y llegado el caso
permitiría cortar el corredor de su
walkie una estrecha franja de tierra en
la frontera por la colituana que podría
impedir el paso de fuerzas de la otan
hacia los países bálticos y tercero por
la propia obsesión de Putin de
restablecer la grandeza de Rusia
esencialmente el mismo motivo que lo ha
empujado a la Guerra de Ucrania
y qué mejor tanto para Putin que ampliar
la madre Rusia y restablecer la grandeza
de su nuevo imperio ya veis que una vez
más las casualidades no existen
para colmó las sanciones internacionales
hicieron que la dependencia de
Bielorrusia con Rusia se multiplicará y
como os podéis imaginar Putin no tuvo
ningún problema en dar un montón de
préstamos para sostener a su nuevo
lacayo y amigos amigas eso es
exactamente lo que explica que tras la
despiada de Invasión rusa de Ucrania no
seríamos encontrado con declaraciones
como estas aquellos que nos reprochan no
sabían que tenemos la alianza más
cercana con la federación rusa con ellos
estamos construyendo un estado único
poderoso e independiente el estado de la
unión hemos estado y estaremos juntos
con la Rusia fraterna nuestra
participación en la operación especial
fue decidida por mí hace mucho tiempo
Alexander lukashenko presidente de
Bielorrusia ahora bien pese a ello El
dictador ha ejecutado un meticuloso plan
de equilibrio durante toda la guerra por
un lado permitió Así que antes de la
invasión 30.000 soldados rusos se
desplegarán en el país estas fueron las
tropas que el día 24 de febrero se
lanzaron sobre kits también permitió que
Rusia utilizara su país para llevar a
cabo un lanzamiento masivo de misiles
contra Ucrania e incluso cuatro días
después participación Lucas 5 revocó la
neutralidad constitucional de su país lo
que ahora le permite a Rusia estacionar
tropas permanentes incluyendo armas
nucleares recordáis lo del Títere de
Putin Pues eso sin embargo lo que no
hizo Bielorrusia fue unirse directamente
a la guerra y ahora la pregunta es por
qué se han disparado los rumores acerca
de que eso puede cambiar Próximamente
significa la creación del contingente
militar conjunto que Bielorrusia está a
punto de cambiar esa postura y sumarse a
la contienda de ser así a que se
enfrentaría exactamente Ucrania Pues
bien veámoslo
tambores de guerra
durante la Guerra Fría este territorio
fue muy importante para la unión
soviética las tropas estacionadas en la
llamada repúblicas socialista soviética
de Bielorrusia tenía en la misión y más
y menos que de ser la punta de lanza del
ejército rojo en caso de que estallar un
conflicto con occidente por eso justo
aquí se podían encontrar gran parte de
los equipos militares más modernos del
Pacto de Varsovia incluyendo una cuarta
parte de todos los misiles balísticos
intercontinentales soviéticos sin
embargo tras la caída de la urs la
situación cambió por completo hoy el
ejército bielorruso es ridículamente
pequeño y terriblemente anticuado casi
todos sus equipos tienen décadas de
antigüedad y proceden del ejército rojo
de hecho este es uno de los pocos países
que gastan más en seguridad interna que
en sus fuerzas armadas es decir quién
Hablamos de una dictadura militar sino
sobre todo de una dictadura policial ahí
es exactamente Ahí es donde el régimen
ha concentrado casi todos sus recursos
porque lo cierto es que el presupuesto
militar apenas supone en torno al 1% del
pib 1700 millones de dólares anuales a
pesar de haber crecido Durante los
últimos años y eso no es todo casi todo
el presupuesto va a parar a gasto
corriente Así que la inversión en compra
de problemas y equipos militares es
minúscula para que os hagáis una idea
entre los años 2014 y 2019 el país
apenas destinó 899 millones de dólares a
esta cuestión una media anual de 180
millones incluyendo la corrupción
y claro El caso es que esta falta de
financiación explica por qué el ejército
bielorruso está formado por apenas unos
50.000 soldados y eso no es todo de esas
tropas se estima que apenas 17.000
estarían actualmente entrenadas y
preparadas para el despliegue Y eso
siendo generosos porque muchas Fuentes
reducen aún más esta estimación a una
horquilla de entre 6.000 Y 10.000
efectivos y para colmó desde el
estallido de la guerra Bielorrusia y él
ha entregado muchísimo material militar
a Rusia no tenemos las tropas ni el
Hardware militar ya se ha entregado
mucho Hardware a la federación rusa Hay
pocas tropas listas para el combate como
máximo unas 7000 y no están listas para
una operación de asalto franca asesor
principal de la líder de la oposición
bielorrusal es bien lana chica nos calla
pero ojo que la falta de tropas no es el
único dato llamativo por ejemplo se
calcula que la fuerza aérea Pues apenas
cuenta con 24 aviones con capacidad de
combate y que el ejército solo podría
contar con unos 200 viejos tanques
soviéticos de 72
lo que sí tienen como medida de usasoria
es una reserva supuestamente de más de
290.000 personas Pero la verdad es que
nadie da un duro porque tengan el
equipamiento y el entrenamiento mínimo
para llegar a ser de alguna utilidad en
esta guerra luego tienen bastante
equipamiento almacenado pero Habría que
ver en qué estado después de Ver el
desastre ruso en Ucrania no parece que
se pueda esperar gran cosa de
Bielorrusia
pero un momento Entonces por qué
demonios se habla tanto de Bielorrusia A
qué bien tantos rumores Y esa especie de
juego militar que se traen últimamente
entre
Moscú y Minsk Pues bien podemos
encontrar tres posibles respuestas
[Música]
en primer lugar los soldados rusos y
bielorrusos que se están desplegando
otra vez en la frontera con Ucrania
podrían tener el objetivo de obligar
aquí a trasladar parte de sus efectivos
a esta zona para prevenir un posible
nuevo ataque esto podría reducir algo la
enorme presión que los rusos están
sufriendo en el este y en el sur de
Ucrania donde como sabéis las tropas
ucranianas están logrando
importantísimos avances incluso hay
quien apunta que de seguir empeorando
las cosas Moscú podría intentar un nuevo
asalto sobre kit Aunque solo fuera para
forzar una negociación o desgastar a las
fuerzas ucranianas en segundo lugar las
tropas bielorrusas podrían utilizarse
para defender la retaguardia o las redes
de suministro de tal forma que Rusia
pudiera enviar más unidades al frente al
tiempo que sigue utilizando el suelo
bielorruso para ataques con misiles y En
tercer lugar puede que lo que esté
pasando sea Exactamente lo contrario que
todos estos anuncios simplemente se
terminen traduciendo en La donación de
los equipos que tiene Bielorrusia de
hecho se están viendo muchos traslados
de material como tanques y toneladas de
munición desde los almacenes bielorrusos
hacia el frente lo que parece
incompatible con Buscar una movilización
militar en el país los líderes militares
están tratando de calmar a las tropas
viendo que no entrarán en la guerra ya
que las tropas están muy preocupadas por
ver el éxito de los ucranianos nadie
quiere luchar por Putin Frank biacorca
asesor principal de la líder de la
oposición bielorrusa es bien lana
chicanos calla Y es que de hecho la
entrada de Bielorrusia la guerra podría
ser incluso contraproducente Por qué
Pues porque por un lado podría terminar
haciendo que Washington le dio a Ucrania
lanzacohetes de largo alcance y por otro
lado podría poner a Lucas en contra las
cuerdas
pensad que la guerra es tremendamente
impopular en Bielorrusia según las
encuestas que se manejan menos del 10%
de la población apoya a participar en la
contienda y de hecho las operaciones de
Sabotaje contra el ejército ruso han
sido frecuentes e incluso altos cargos
Como por ejemplo el viceministro de
defensa han llegado a de emitir Como
protesta el apoyo a Rusia Por supuesto
que Putin tiene mucha influencia pero no
puedo obligar a lukasenko a suicidarse
políticamente artiones rayman analista
político bielorruso Ya lo veis hablamos
de un país que tiene poco que aportar
Más allá de viejos equipos quería saber
tú en qué estado se encuentran Claro que
si esta guerra se está caracterizando
por algo es por la falta de racionalidad
de Moscú Y eso pues quién sabe podría
llegar a contagiar a sus compinches sea
como sea lo que está claro es que el
régimen de lukashenko ha sido cómplice
de una inhumana y cruel ola de violencia
y terror y por eso su régimen tiene que
estar en la Diana de todas las sanciones
internacionales pero dicho esto llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti crees que
finalmente veremos a Bielorrusia
declarándole la guerra a Ucrania y se
está la penúltima bala que se guarda
Moscú para intentar convertir La derrota
que está sufriendo Cómo crees que
evolucionará este conflicto déjanos por
aquí abajo tus comentarios y ahora si
este vídeo te resultó interesante No
olvides darle a like y suscribirte si es
que aún no lo has hecho Échale también
un vistazo
100% recomendables Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]